>> Narrator: From the Library
of Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Stephen Winick: So my name
is Stephen Winick and I'm here
at the Library of Congress,
where I'm the writer and editor
for the American Folklife Center.
And I'm here with the three members
of the group NOKA,
and with Mikel Markez.
And we're going to
talk about Basque music
and culture, and about their group.
So I'm going to address some
general questions in English,
and any of you can answer.
And I also have some questions
in French that I'll ask later
for Mikel specifically --
>> Mikel Markez: Okay.
>> Stephen Winick: About the
Basque country and life there.
But for now, you are
three Basque-Americans,
and perform Basque
language songs and music.
So let's talk a little
about the Basque culture,
and if you could just start out
by telling us what, you know,
Americans need to know about
Basque culture to understand
who are the Basques, and what's
their language and culture like?
>> Begoña Echeverria: Well, the
Basque country is a translation
from the English of Euskal
Herria, which were the first two
of the seven provinces, where the
language, Basque has been spoken.
So there are -- right now it's
divided into seven provinces.
Four which are in Spain and
three of which are in France.
But there's a language there
that is spoken that is unrelated
to any other language in the
world, so it's an isolate --
so it's not related to Spanish
or French, or anything else.
So in America what they should know,
is it's a great secret language.
So everyone should learn
it -- not everybody --
enough people should
learn it so they can talk
about other people while
they're in America.
And so we are -- the three of us
are daughters, or granddaughters
of immigrants who came
from the Basque country.
From -- my family's from the
southern side, so the northwest
of France, and Nafarroa
[Beherea] is the province,
about five miles from
the French border.
So my parents came from
there to work in the states.
And Cathy and Andrea can speak
to their own family histories.
>> Cathy Petrissans: My
parents were born in California;
it's my grandfathers
that immigrated to --
one to Chino and one
to northern California.
They married Basque-American women,
so my grandmothers were
also born in California.
They came from the French
side of the Basque country.
>> Andréa Bidart: Yeah,
my parents also were born
in the French side of
the Basque country.
My mom's from Alsace, and my
father's from St. Estevan.
And my father immigrated as
a shepherd in the mid-50s,
and then he got into
the dairy business.
And went back to marry my mom after
seven years, and that's my history.
>> Stephen Winick: Great.
Well you know, I think if Americans
know about Basque Americans at all,
they tend to associate
them, I think, with Idaho
and possibly with Nevada.
I'm not sure that a
lot of Americans know
that there's Basque
folks in California.
So are the Basques in
the West generally aware
of one another's communities
as well as the other states?
>> Cathy Petrissans: Yes, we have --
in California the biggest Basque
clubs are in Chino where we're from.
There's one in Bakersfield
and San Francisco.
And those are ones that each
have their own clubhouse.
So yes, we do know each other very
well; we go to each other's picnics.
There's -- well the picnics for
the children, the kids get together
and learn dances together
and songs together, but yes,
we know each other very well.
>> Stephen Winick: Mm-hm.
>> Andréa Bidart: And
it's also connected
through the North American
Basque Organization.
And there are like triannual
meetings, and communication.
We have a website, so --
>> Stephen Winick: Mm-hm.
So what kind of Basque cultural
outlets are there in California?
You mentioned the clubs,
are there other sort of ways
in which Basques get together and --
>> Begoña Echeverria: Sure --
>> Stephen Winick: And
perform their culture?
>> Begoña Echeverria:
So in addition to --
we call them Basque picnics.
So they're big -- they
are pretty big festivals.
So the Basque community will
have Basque picnics in --
every year at the same time.
So the Basque picnics
and the different communities
will go to each other's picnics.
So we tend to go to the
ones in Bakersfield;
they'll come to our picnics.
And then depending on the community,
but we have an actual clubhouse
-- a Chino Basque club.
So we actually have
monthly gatherings,
and we'll have lunches or dinners.
And we'll have -- we've brought
people over from the Basque Country,
like Mikel's been there
before with other singers.
And we've brought over Kepa Junkera.
[Inaudible] has been there; we've
had dance groups perform there.
But even when we don't
have entertainment
from the Basque Country,
we'll get together
and have a meal that's
prepared by Basque-Americans
or Basque immigrants, and just
to spend some time together.
>> Cathy Petrissans: There are
also some Basque restaurants.
>> Begoña Echeverria: Yeah,
Basque restaurants, sure.
>> Cathy Petrissans: In
Chino we only have one.
Now Bakersfield has I
don't know, maybe four
or five Basque restaurants.
San Francisco has one as well.
And back in the day, I mean in Chino
it was where all the shepherds came.
They were boarders there, so the
owners -- the woman, Monique,
she would cook for all of the
shepherds; that's where they lived.
Andréa Bidart: And it's organized
into communities, and you --
each community has usually
its own dance group.
So we have like three
Basque dance groups.
To the littlest ones, and
then the older ones and on up.
And then we have the
sport too, pilota.
Like in Chino we have the young
ones learning how to do pilota.
And there's a lot of
card game going on.
Mouche is the standard card game.
I know my mother plays
at least twice a week.
And then each club
has its competition,
and then there's the
national competition.
And it goes international
competition, so --
>> Stephen Winick: Wow.
>> Andréa Bidart: So yeah.
>> Cathy Petrissans:
It's pretty organized.
>> Andréa Bidart: It
is pretty organized.
>> Stephen Winick: Yeah, wow.
So in terms of song, I mean
you guys ended up as --
with song as sort of your
primary expression of your --
>> Cathy Petrissans: Right.
>> Stephen Winick: Basque identity.
So is that an important part of
Basque life in California as well?
>> Begoña Echeverria: Sure.
I mean I think that one of the
main things the Basque movement has
brought I think was
the love of song.
And there's an old -- I think
it's a French saying that
"The Basques are the
people who sing".
I've heard that before.
And Basques usually do know how
to sing, and it's a tradition
in the Basque-American communities.
This is true both in the
California world where we're used
to seeing, you know, Basque people.
But even in Idaho or other
places, where after dinner --
after any meal really,
there's those long tables
and people will sit
around and sing songs.
So All of us grew up I think
hearing Basque song around the table
at Basque restaurants or
picnics or in our homes --
>> Cathy Petrissans: Our
fathers sing together.
>> Begoña Echeverria: Yeah,
all of our fathers sing.
>> Cathy Petrissans: Yeah.
Yeah, so --
>> Andréa Bidart: But
also song in church.
>> Begoña Echeverria: Yeah.
Mm-hm.
>> Andréa Bidart: Basques are
usually Catholic, and so we all grew
up singing the church songs.
And then song comes into --
there's a Basque camp for children,
and they learn all
the different things.
And Noka as a group has gone
to Udaleku and taught songs
that would teach the
language to the children.
>> Stephen Winick: Mm-hm.
>> Andréa Bidart: Through song.
>> Stephen Winick: Right.
>> Cathy Petrissans: And in those
masses, when people pass away,
they call on NOKA to
do those Basque songs.
>> Stephen Winick: Right.
>> Cathy Petrissans: You know, two
of us can do it, because Cathy's
in Pennsylvania, or any form
of us we can kind of help out.
>> Andréa Bidart: But
we've sung at many --
>> Cathy Petrissans:
In that fashion too.
>> Andréa Bidart: Many funerals.
>> Cathy Petrissans: Right.
>> Stephen Winick: Mm-hm.
>> Cathy Petrissans:
Weddings too [laughs].
>> Begoña Echeverria:
Yes, every now and again.
>> Andréa Bidart: Some baptisms.
>> Stephen Winick: So --
sure, so are there a lot
of traditional Basque
songs in oral tradition
in California would you say?
Or -- ?
>> Begoña Echeverria: I
would say most of them are.
I mean I think that we're
one of the few groups --
we might be the only group
in California, actually,
that is writing our own music -- our
own songs, and trying to find songs
that are less traditional.
So the songs -- we love
those songs, or if we have --
our CD with Mikel is our third
CD, but the first two we did --
the first one was really --
>> Cathy Petrissans:
All traditional songs.
>> Begoña Echeverria: Here are
songs we heard up, you know --
>> Cathy Petrissans: Yeah.
>> Begoña Echeverria: -- singing
and learning, and so they're --
and so those songs are
really the -- kind of the --
and I think it's pretty typical
of immigrant communities,
but you know, missing the homeland.
And seeing their mother and
seeing their sweetheart,
and wanting a sweetheart, and
those kind of heartbreaking songs.
And we love those.
So a lot of ballads.
So I would say the norm is to --
you know, people have books
where they memorize them
to sing those songs.
And we're trying to do a little bit
-- we do that too, but we're trying
to kind of bring into more
public view the kind of songs
that people don't generally sing.
>> Stephen Winick:
And when you say that,
what kind of songs would that be?
>> Begoña Echeverria: Well, I
would say that there are a few songs
that I personally grew up
hearing that were where the women
or girls were protagonists.
I mean they're sort
of the object of --
like maybe a man want to marry them,
or they miss them, or the girls --
that someone's telling them what to
do, but they don't have much say.
And -- but we've really, in the
archives, have found a lot of songs
that are -- like in today's
concert -- that are --
and very often bad things
are happening to them.
But women's stories;
a woman struggling.
Or a woman who's a saint.
Or a woman who has to go
someplace to, you know, find work
and then gets in trouble.
Or two sisters fighting.
And we don't have, you know,
the bickering over a boy.
So we're trying to really find --
uncover and write songs that
about sort of putting women more
in the forefront and not just in
the secondary or supporting roles,
and sort of what men
want them to be.
But kind of having
their own opinions
about what they want to do or be.
>> Stephen Winick: Mm-hm.
Great, that's really, you know,
I think a really interesting
approach to song --
>> Begoña Echeverria: Mm-hm.
>> Stephen Winick:
Especially from a group
that got its start doing
traditional songs --
>> Begoña Echeverria: Right.
>> Stephen Winick:
Because of that --
you know, the sort of gender roles.
>> Begoña Echeverria: And then we
also see our fathers, I mean they --
Cathy, her mother sings about --
>> Cathy Petrissans: Right.
>> Stephen Winick: Right.
>> Begoña Echeverria: We learned it
from our fathers and grandfathers --
>> Cathy Petrissans: And
my grandfather would sing
around the table all
the time, so for --
I think it was a very positive
thing is what it was to be Basque;
to sing songs around the table.
>> Stephen Winick: Right.
And so explain the connection
of that focus on women's stories
with the -- the name, NOKA.
>> Begoña Echeverria: Well,
if you insist [laughs].
So NOKA is the name of our group,
and we named ourselves
after a pronoun.
Because in Basque there is no
he or she or "la" or "elle".
The only place where there's gender
marking is in the familiar form.
And there's one form of how
we're speaking to Mikel,
called "Toka" [phonetic].
Or if I'm speaking to Cathy
or Andrea, it's called "Noka".
So it's to one female
addressee or a girl or a woman.
And it really marks a relationship
of a familiarity or solidarity.
But as you've seen in
the concert what ends
up happening is it's used
not for sort of positive
or friendship purposes, but
for telling a girl what to do,
or to address to women who are
not necessarily looked well upon.
So we thought that was
really interesting,
and then that it's dying.
So it's equivalent to the male
form, Toka, but it's not used
in nearly sort of the context.
And the Toka form; the male form,
has these positive association
with this rugged, you know
[foreign language spoken],
the eye candy, right?
Like they're really sexy
and masculine, and you know.
Or they're poets or
they're athletes,
or they're in the public
domain doing great things.
And the Noka form is
not used that way.
So we thought, well we should
sing those songs to kind
of show the richness of the form.
And then also we've been writing
songs and using them in ways
that are more just familiar,
and more pedestrian puroposes
to show what it should be.
And it used to be used
for everything.
Because it was the only way to speak
to a single addressee;
a singular addressee.
So we've been trying to expand the
range of uses that we sing in song.
>> Stephen Winick: Mm-hm.
I notice you've mentioned a couple
of times finding songs
in the archive --
>> Begoña Echeverria: Yes.
>> Stephen Winick: Or bringing
songs out of the archive.
So where do you locate the archive?
Where -- ?
>> Begoña Echeverria: They're in
my house [background laughter] --
so now they're in my house.
So I -- I'm a sociologist of
language, and I did research
for my dissertation on efforts
to revitalize the language
in San Sabastian, Gipuzkoa.
And when I was doing that
research, I noticed that this is
when I first learned about
the Noka/Toka difference.
And people didn't have
a different --
didn't have a good answer to when I
would ask -- well why don't people,
because to me like, the "tu"
form in Spanish is like --
>> Stephen Winick: Yeah [laughs].
>> Begoña Echeverria:
Everybody uses it.
So I didn't understand
why it wasn't used
in the same way as the male form.
And no one had an answer.
"Oh no, that's just the way it
is; it's always been that way."
And I'm, "Okay."
So I started looking in the archives
to see, well how has it been used?
And there's sort of
three main archival --
there's three main genres I guess.
There's a lot of song.
There's a lot of folklore, and
then there's Biblical materials.
>> Stephen Winick: Mm-hm.
>> Begoña Echeverria: So
I've looked at all of that.
And interestingly enough, a
lot of the best materials are
in the Bodleian Library in Oxford
-- which I love that place so much.
So a lot of it's there.
Some of them are in archives
in the Basque country.
And then some of them are also
in the Center for Basque Studies
at University of Nevada, Reno.
So I've spent a lot of time
in the archives very happily,
and I've copied the
songs or I buy the books.
And so most of what we
need for singers is all
in my house now [laughs].
So I have copies somewhere
in my house.
>> Stephen Winick: That's great.
So we love to hear about
people using the archives here
at the Library of Congress,
as you well know --
>> Begoña Echeverria: Yes, we do
-- and I must say, I also spend time
in the Alan Lomax collection,
looking at the Basque songs,
and he knows -- of him too.
So I actually have
looked at those --
the Basque sources in the
Library of Congress as well.
>> Stephen Winick: Right.
That's great --
>> Begoña Echeverria: Yeah.
>> Stephen Winick:
-- and just those --
that's a collection that's in
the division where I work --
>> Begoña Echeverria:
Yeah, we love it.
Yeah, it's great.
>> Stephen Winick: The
American Folklore Center --
>> Begoña Echeverria: Yeah.
Yeah.
>> Stephen Winick: Where Alan
Lomax went to the Basque country --
>> Begoña Echeverria: Yeah.
Yeah.
>> Stephen Winick: And collected
a lot of songs and music.
>> Begoña Echeverria: Yeah.
Yeah.
>> Stephen Winick: Great.
Well thanks for accessing that
kind of gem, because we love it.
>> Begoña Echeverria:
Oh, I loved it.
Yeah. And he also spent some time
in Baztan, which is where my --
the valley where my family's from.
So he spent time at Elizondo.
And one of his informants
was Mariano Izeta.
>> Mikel Markez: Right.
>> Begoña Echeverria: And he was
a jeweler on the side [laughs].
He was this -- you know, I
mean he wrote a dictionary
and he was sort of a folklorist.
And so some of the songs that are
on that collection from the 50s,
he's like - he's like 35 and he died
when he was I don't
know, 85 or something.
So it was - I knew
him as an older man.
>> Stephen Winick: Right.
>> Begoña Echeverria: So it was
like, hey, this is Mariano Izeta,
singing on this collection!
It's really great.
>> Stephen Winick: Wonderful.
Well we always love to hear
stories like that, so thanks.
>> Begoña Echeverria: Yeah.
>> Stephen Winick: Another thing
that I noticed during the concert
was that you set some Basque lyrics
to contemporary songwriter's
music --
>> Begoña Echeverria: Mm-hm.
Mm-hm.
>> Stephen Winick: Including
Johnny Cash and John Prime.
>> Begoña Echeverria: Mm-hm.
>> Stephen Winick: So how
did you come to do that?
>> Andréa Bidart: I guess
that was mostly my idea
and they were willing to --
>> Begoña Echeverria: It
was mostly her idea [laughs].
>> Andréa Bidart: Go along with it.
I mean as Begona said earlier, we
started off with traditional tunes,
and then we took other Basque tunes
and then either put them in Noka,
or took them out of the Archives.
And then most recently
we've been thinking more
about being Basque-American.
And so taking the words in Noka and
then setting them to American tunes.
I think particularly be of
interest to the Basque --
you know, in the Basque region who,
I think, really like American music.
>> Cathy Petrissans: It's different.
Nobody's doing it [laughs].
>> Andréa Bidart: But that's not
what they're doing over there,
so it's a way to Basque-American.
>> Stephen Winick: Mm-hm.
And when you write your own songs,
do you write the words
and the music primarily?
>> Begoña Echeverria: I don't
know anything about music [laughs],
I don't read music or anything.
So I go with the words.
>> Stephen Winick: Mm-hm.
>> Begoña Echeverria: So
when I write the lyrics --
so the first song, the
one about the coffee milk?
I mean that was a tune
that I loved for so long.
And it was before I even knew
Cathy's uncle had written it.
And I remember I was on a plane and
the tune kept coming back to me.
And I -- if I don't know the meter,
my favorite meter seems
to be 8, 10 -- 8,6.
So I just started out -- the
words just started coming
and I sort of went with it.
So for me to write the lyrics, I
almost always have a tune in mind,
and then sometimes we use that
tune or we don't; we change it up.
And then there was
only a couple times
when I've just written the
words without any music at all.
And then in a couple cases, Cathy
found a tune that kind of went
with it and she arranged the words.
But that's sort of been
my process; I don't know.
>> Andréa Bidart: And
then with Mikel Markez --
>> Begoña Echeverria: Yeah.
>> Andréa Bidart: Our
collaboration with him,
that's when he was writing
the tune and Begona's words --
>> Stephen Winick: I see.
>> Andréa Bidart:
And that would be,
for instance, [Basque
language spoken]
>> Cathy Petrissans:
Because he can write a song
in like 15 minutes [laughs].
>> Andréa Bidart:
Yeah, we spent that --
>> Begoña Echeverria: Yeah,
one of them was 20 minutes I
think I sent him the words,
and then he had a tune
in 20 minutes.
It was a little -- a little bit
gross [background laughter].
Because I don't think he has
any musical training either,
so he just sort of comes up with it.
>> Andréa Bidart: But that was
two summers ago that he came --
>> Begoña Echeverria: Yeah.
>> Mikel Markez: Right.
>> Andréa Bidart: And spent
time with us, and that --
and we recorded, and we're
just working together.
And he'd come out with -- we'd show
him the words, and he would come
out with a tune or vice-versa.
>> Cathy Petrissans: [Basque
language spoken] is mostly ours --
>> Begoña Echeverria: That's true.
That's true --
>> Cathy Petrissans:
Wouldn't you say?
>> Begoña Echeverria: That's true.
>> Cathy Petrissans: The words
and a little bit -- a twist of --
>> Andréa Bidart: Yeah, a twist
on the traditional, but -- and --
or sometimes we just
change the rhythm
up to make it-- like
the Santa Agata.
>> Cathy Petrissans: Mm-hm.
>> Andréa Bidart: That melody
existed, but we just gave it a,
you know, "Mack the
Knife" kind of feel to it.
>> Stephen Winick: Mm-hm.
>> Andréa Bidart: And really
changed the whole feeling
of that song.
>> Stephen Winick: Right.
And well, explain that song.
Explain the sort of
idea of that song.
>> Begoña Echeverria: Well, I
mean I think Cathy can speak more
to the musical side of it,
but I -- it's another --
song I had at my house
[laughs] in a book, and I --
I had heard, and I don't
know that much about it,
and maybe you can ask him
later-- in French, maybe he knows,
but it's just she's a
Sicilian saint, and she --
a Roman governor wanted her to be
his concubine, and she refused.
And he wanted her -- and I think
he put her in a brothel, to like,
"Okay" -- and she still refused.
And then she -- he put
her in a prison and she --
and then said, "Give up your
Christian faith" and she refused.
So then he actually had her martyred
as if she were a prostitute.
>> Stephen Winick: Mm-hm.
>> Begoña Echeverria: So the
martyrdom is really brutal.
And so I don't know why she is a
patron saint of some small towns
in the Basque country,
I don't know why.
>> Cathy Petrissans: Yeah,
Mikel will probably know that.
>> Begoña Echeverria: but there --
Biscay and I think
it's mostly Biscay.
And I know that because in
Boise, a lot of the -- most --
that community mostly went
to -- it's from Biscay.
So they do this -- sort of on
her feast day, they do this --
they sing a version of her
story that's very sanitized --
>> Stephen Winick: Mm-hm.
>> Cathy Petrissans:
In those communities.
But it was new to us.
And so in -- there's many
versions of that song.
And the -- and most of
them don't tell the story,
they just say, "She
was really awesome.
She was really faithful.
Go Agatha."
And -- but this song is like --
this is what happened to her.
This is what happened to her,
and we thought, you know,
we've had different responses
to that song, but you're going
to remember the story [laughs].
>> Stephen Winick: Yeah.
>> Begoña Echeverria:
Even if you hate it.
You're going to -- yeah.
>> Andréa Bidart: But interesting
to me too, children sing that song.
It's sort of like a
trick-or-treat kind of a thing.
They go in the streets, right?
And they bang their canes.
And they're asking for candy.
And it's very --
>> Cathy Petrissans: He's going to
know about Saint Agatha; ask him.
>> Stephen Winick: Saint Agatha?
>> Andréa Bidart: You
know, straight and solid.
>> Cathy Petrissans: Yeah.
He'll know.
>> Begoña Echeverria:
We don't know why it was.
>> Andréa Bidart: And so
because it was in Noka,
we tried to think hard how
can we reinterpret this song,
and that's when the whole kind
of jazzy feeling came from it.
>> Stephen Winick: Mikel,
parlez un peu de Sainte Agata?
[Mikel, speak a little
about St. Agatha]
>> Mikel Markez: Oui.
[Yes.]
>>Mikel Markez: C'est un tradition,
Sainte Agathe, comme elles ont dit,
surtout a Bizkaia, c'est plus,
mais dans tout le pays Basque.
Et la tradition c'est d'aller
le nuit avant Sainte Agathe,
le jour de Sainte Agathe, et aller
dans les maisons qui sont dans le
village et dans les montagnes
aussi, avec des bois...
>> Cathy Petrissans:
Yeah, wood -- wood sticks.
>> Begoña Echeverria:
A cane -- canes.
>>Mikel Markez: Et tout le monde va
a une maison et chante les verses
que nous avons chantés aujourd'hui.
Et c'est pour demander des
oeufs ou un petit peu de pain,
ou un peu de lait.
Ou quelque chose.
Et ils chantent:
[Singing in Basque Language]
>>Mikel Markez: Et c'est un
rythme archaïque, avec les....
Et tout le monde est là.
Il y a des enfants, des
vieux, et tout le monde va.
C'est un tradition
millénaire, je pense.
>> Stephen Winick:
Merci, [laughs] all right.
>> Begoña Echeverria: And we --
that's not the version
that we sing [laughs].
>> Stephen Winick: Right, but
still, you know very interesting.
>> Begoña Echeverria: We don't
say give us candy [laughs].
That's good.
>> Stephen Winick: So I guess we
didn't talk about how you're --
how the three of you started
singing together as a group,
like as a performance group.
>> Cathy Petrissans: We started in
1997 really, singing in English.
We recorded a song,
"The Rose" in English.
>> Stephen Winick: Mm-hm.
>> Cathy Petrissans: And
after that we decided, well,
that turned out pretty well,
why don't we sing in Basque?
We had sung together in a group
called [Basque language spoken],
a group of women in Chino before.
But that's really what made us, just
the three of us, separate and --
we were first the American
Basque Chicks for a little --
>> Begoña Echeverria:
Just for a little bit.
>> Cathy Petrissans: ABC,
and then Noka came about.
>> Stephen Winick: Excellent.
>> Cathy Petrissans: So it's really
almost 20 years ago that we started.
>> Stephen Winick: Mm-hm.
And did you seek a connection with
the kind of the Basque music scene?
Because I know there's a lot of
music over in the Basque country.
>> Cathy Petrissans: Mm-hm.
>> Stephen Winick: So did you start
travelling there to see any of that?
>> Cathy Petrissans:
Well we've all --
>> Stephen Winick: See any of that?
>> Cathy Petrissans: We've always
sort of travelled there, I mean --
>> Andréa Bidart: But as a
group that took us some time.
>> Cathy Petrissans:
Really not yearly, but --
yeah, it took us some
time to do that.
Our first CDs we really did on our
own, without really collaborating
with any musicians from over there.
>> Stephen Winick: Mm-hm.
>> Cathy Petrissans: I would
say, the first two CDs.
>> Begoña Echeverria: Yeah, and I
think that that first CD was songs
that we knew, and then -- so we knew
the songs, and then we -- I think --
was that the one your
family was involved in?
The musicians--
>> Andréa Bidart:
Yeah, mostly yeah.
Because we didn't know anyone, so --
>> Begoña Echeverria:
But it was sort of kind --
we didn't really change
much up on that one.
We just sort of, "This is
kind of how we know them."
And then we sang them that way.
And then the second
CD was more, "Okay,
we're going to sing only songs
in Noka", and those were --
and some of those were
a little bit different.
But it's the first -- this CD
with Mikel is the first time
that we have a collaboration
from the very beginning
with a Basque-American,
and Basque musician.
And we thought kind of deliberately
together about both the theme
of the song, and then you
know, what kind of came easily,
musically in the arrangement.
And we kind of went with
those that kind of came
to all of us that we liked.
>> Stephen Winick: Mm-hm.
And how did you start
collaborating with Mikel?
>> Cathy Petrissans: Well actually,
well he came to Chino, and I --
you know, four years ago
[foreign language spoken]?
>> Mikel Markez: Four years, yeah.
>> Cathy Petrissans:
And I didn't see him
over there; Begona had met him.
>> Begoña Echeverria: Yeah.
>> Cathy Petrissans: And
then I met him separately
in the Basque Country three years
ago, and we started talking.
And then he had recorded
his last CD that he asked me
to be a collaborator
on, so I did that.
And I just saw it was really easy to
work with him, so then I said, "Hey,
we should do something with Noka."
So that's really how it started.
>> Stephen Winick: Great.
>> Cathy Petrissans: So I've been
working with him on his projects.
>> Stephen Winick: Great.
And another aspect
in the performance
that you gave us today was the
projection screen with some
of the lyrics and some
explanations of some of the songs.
How did it come to your minds
to do that -- to add that?
>> Begoña Echeverria:
Well we actually initially start
off doing this kind of a format.
Because we primarily -- we
started off primarily performing
to American audiences;
sometimes Basque-American,
but sometimes university audiences.
And so no one understands
the language.
And so from the beginning,
we sort of --
we've had the lyrics and
then the translation.
And then we try to keep the
images interesting [laughs].
And so then -- so this is -- what
we did today is actually what we --
until recently we would do
pretty much all the time,
and sort of more lecture
performances.
And often when we do that, I
have actually many more slides
about the grammar which I didn't
show today, to kind of talk
about [background laughter] --
because people usually
don't know anything --
they don't know where
the Basque country is.
They don't know where we --
I mean sometimes they do,
but in university settings.
So we'll have, you know,
here's our Basque Country.
Here's our map.
And here's, you know, the
language and all that.
And so from the very beginning,
it's sort of been not only to sing,
but also to educate the public
about the Basque country;
about the Basque language.
And in particular about Noka.
Because even native speakers
over there often won't know --
they won't even know
what it is really.
So I think we've been more
deliberate about trying to --
when we learn something that
is a surprise, to be sure
and talk about that in the talk.
>> Stephen Winick: Mm-hm.
And so this year is
kind of special --
>> Begoña Echeverria: Mm-hm.
>> Stephen Winick: Because the
Basque country's being featured
at the Smithsonian
Folklife Festival.
So what's that experience
been like for you [laughs]?
>> Andréa Bidart:
It's been wonderful.
And one thing I was
hoping that would come
out of it would be
collaborating with other cultures.
And we've had that
opportunity because we're part
of the Basque program,
but we're also part
of the Sounds of California program.
>> Stephen Winick: Sure.
>> Andréa Bidart: So we've
already had a wonderful experience
with the Japanese group --
>> Cathy Petrissans: Japanese,
yeah, from Los Angeles.
>> Andréa Bidart: And
we had a panel with them.
And we decided collectively
to teach them a Basque song.
And then they taught
us a Japanese song.
And we were able to perform
those together, and for me,
those kinds of things
are a highlight.
>> Stephen Winick: Mm-hm.
>> Begoña Echeverria: Yeah.
And we have a -- I think two days or
three days we have another session
at the -- Sounds of California
in the studio with a --
I think they call themselves
the Armenian Public Radio.
>> Stephen Winick: Okay.
>> Begoña Echeverria: So it's
like [laughs], okay, so we --
and you know, what's
interesting to us is
that often they're
really close to us,
and we don't know about each other.
So it's sort of fun to make --
it's been fun making those
kinds of connections.
>> Stephen Winick: Mm-hm.
>> Cathy Petrissans: And just how
many people in such a short amount
of time are learning about
Basque in a positive way.
Because you know, sometimes
like, "Oh Basque" you know,
with the political
problems and its --
>> Stephen Winick: Right.
>> Cathy Petrissans: This is
really what Basques are about too,
and just sharing that with
everybody has been great.
>> Stephen Winick: Actually that's
an interesting question too,
because a lot of Americans
who only know one thing
about Basque people might know
about the separatist movement
in Spain and in France.
So how does that affect
the sort of scene,
or the way Basque-Americans
approach, and --
>> Cathy Petrissans: I don't know,
for me I feel like we're not
really part of that at all.
I mean I've never really felt
that that's affected what
we do, or how we say things.
>> Begoña Echeverria: And I think
that that's -- I would
agree with that.
I think that's primarily because
the communities that we're from,
they were on the -- mostly all from
the French side, on [inaudible].
>> Stephen Winick: Mm-hm.
>> Begoña Echeverria: And they came
because they came from big families
and the oldest child
got the house --
>> Stephen Winick: Yeah [laughs].
>> Begoña Echeverria: And the
rest had to fend for themselves.
>> Stephen Winick: Yeah.
>> Begoña Echeverria: So
they didn't come to the west.
They didn't come really --
they came for economic reasons,
like other immigrants; they didn't
come for political reasons, so --
and what has happened in
Nevada and California,
and in -- I'm forgetting a state.
>> Stephen Winick: Idaho?
>> Begoña Echeverria:
No, Idaho's not --
but for Nevada and California,
it's been mostly immigrants
from the northern side,
from the French side --
>> Stephen Winick: Mm-hm.
>> Begoña Echeverria: And
really close to the French border
on Spanish like my family.
And they -- their Lingua
Franca became Basque [laughs].
Because they either came
to be French and Basque --
>> Stephen Winick: Right.
>> Begoña Echeverria: Or Spanish
and Basque, but not English,
and not the other language.
And so what's been interesting
is in a lot of places, they --
in some cases I think some of the --
even the immigrants spoke
more Basque once they got here
than they had at home.
Because when they were at home there
weren't schools in their language,
or they had -- they were more used
to speaking French or Spanish.
But when they got here, the language
they had in common was Basque.
Which is very interesting.
>> Stephen Winick: That
is very interesting, yeah.
>> Begoña Echeverria: Yeah.
>> Cathy Petrissans:
I've known people
to actually learn Basque in Chino.
>> Begoña Echeverria: Yeah.
>> Cathy Petrissans: And from the
Spanish side they weren't able
to speak Basque --
>> Stephen Winick: Mm-hm.
>> Cathy Petrissans:
During the time of Franco.
>> Begoña Echeverria: Yeah.
>> Cathy Petrissans: And
they came to California
and they learned it,
so it's [laughs].
>> Stephen Winick:
That's great [laughs].
>> Cathy Petrissans:
There are cases like that.
>> Stephen Winick: Yeah.
So how is the language culture of
Basque doing, both in California
and back in the home country?
>> Begoña Echeverria:
Well, I mean it's --
there have been efforts
on -- mostly on --
in three of the four
provinces on the Spanish side,
and Mikel can speak to that --
>> Stephen Winick: Mm-hm.
Sure.
>> Begoña Echeverria:
Since 1982 I think, where --
after Franco died [laughs] --
>> Stephen Winick: Right.
>> Begoña Echeverria:
And Democracy came back.
So had to wait a long
time for that to happen.
So even under Franco's regime, there
were clandestine Basque schools.
And then once he died in 1975
-- after a very long time --
and Democracy returned, there --
some communities were allowed to
use their language in the schools --
in public -- for free,
for public schools.
So that's helped a lot in
parts of the Basque country,
because you know, for the first time
-- for first time in a long time,
people could speak it publicly
and there was support for that.
So if you wanted to send your
child to a Basque school for free,
you could do that from
the age three on.
So there's a lot more people who
can speak Basque in those regions
than previously, so I think --
I've heard anywhere between --
like the total number
of between 750,000
to a million people worldwide.
>> Stephen Winick: Mm-hm.
>> Begoña Echeverria: So
that sounds pretty good.
And it's better than it was,
but the problem is, you know,
we're not out of the woods
yet, because most people
who speak Basque speak
something else most of the time.
>> Stephen Winick: Right.
>> Begoña Echeverria:
They speak Spanish or --
mostly Spanish or French.
It's not taught so much
in the homes anymore.
The people are learning
it at school.
And we know how that is to
learn a language at school,
you're like, eh, what is this for?
>> Stephen Winick: Mm-hm.
>> Begoña Echeverria: And so
there's still a lot of issues
with the language in terms
of -- I mean it's still --
it's better institutionally than it
was, but it's still not as strong
as Spanish and French in terms of
where it is located institutionally.
So -- so there's that.
And in the -- in Basque-America,
I mean I think we're typical
of other immigrant communities
where, you know, maybe I would say,
perhaps of Cathy and
our generation --
the daughters and sons
of immigrants,
maybe 1 in 3 learned Basque?
>> Stephen Winick: Mm-hm.
>> Begoña Echeverria:
You know, which is --
you know, so I'm one of those three.
>> Stephen Winick: Right.
>> Begoña Echeverria: But that was
just because who my parents were.
But by the second generation, it's
-- very, very few people know it.
Because by that point
-- so if it's people
of my generation, English
is still better.
And then, you know, even if
both speak Basque and English,
English is their language together.
>> Stephen Winick: Mm-hm.
>> Begoña Echeverria: Just
like in the -- so that's --
their normal language is English,
and then their language of education
and profession is English.
And it's -- there aren't schools, so
it's possible, but it's difficult.
I think people have a lot of
affection for the language,
and they like to sing along to
words that they may not even know.
But there's not been institutional
support that you would have
in some other languages I think.
>> Stephen Winick: So I guess
you guys have a mission [laughs].
>> Begoña Echeverria: We do.
>> Andréa Bidart: We do.
>> Cathy Petrissans: Got work to do.
>> Stephen Winick: That's great.
>> Begoña Echeverria: We do -- and
a lot of what we've been working
on too is just -- just I think we
have to give ourselves a break.
You know, the best way to be a
Basque speaker in California is
to be born to my parents [laughs].
Because it has nothing to do
with me [laughs] it was a completely
normal thing for them to do.
So I think often people get blamed
for not passing on a language --
>> Stephen Winick: Right.
>> Begoña Echeverria: Even though
there were good reasons for it.
They were told not to, or it was
illegal or dangerous, or both.
And I think -- and then sometimes
later on people are like,
"Oh why didn't you
teach me this language?"
"Well, because at the time,
there were good reasons
why we didn't teach you.
We thought you were doing --
we were doing the right thing."
So -- and I think that sometimes
people will give people a hard time
for not having made
-- and often women --
like the mother, they're like,
"Well you should've done this mom."
[Background laughter] and it's not
-- you know, it's not very nice.
>> Stephen Winick: Yeah, leave aside
the shame and blame, and just --
>> Begoña Echeverria: Exactly.
"Oh yeah, so I should have
anticipated 30 years ago -- "
>> Stephen Winick: And
just -- just learn it.
Yeah [laughs].
>> Begoña Echeverria:
That you would've wanted
to speak this language, thanks.
>> Cathy Petrissans:
Well, my bad [laughs].
>> Begoña Echeverria:
Yeah, sorry [laughs].
>> Cathy Petrissans:
Yeah, maybe next time.
>> Stephen Winick: Well, I think
song and music is a great way
into any language culture.
>> Begoña Echeverria: Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah.
>> Stephen Winick: So I think you
guys are doing the right thing.
>> Begoña Echeverria:
Well hopefully.
We like it anyway.
Yeah.
>> Stephen Winick: Well I'm going
to ask Mikel a few questions,
and because of the language issue,
I'm going to ask those in French,
and I'll provide a translation
of course for our video.
So --
>> Stephen Winick: Parlons un
peu des traditions populaires des
Basques dans le pays
Basque lui-même.
Est-ce-qu'il y a beaucoup de gens
qui jouent la musique traditionelle?
>> Mikel Markez: Oui, il y a.
Nous avons eu beaucoup de gens
comme...Alan Lomax, no?
Qui a pris des vieux chansons.
Et nous étions aux années 60,
un groupe très intéressant...parce
que, dans la partie Espagnole,
il y avait un dictatuer,
comme vous a dit Begoña,
et la langage était interdit.
Et dans les 60, il est un peu de...
[Basque language spoken]
>> Begoña Echeverria:
Yeah research --
>> Cathy Petrissans: Research.
>> Mikel Markez: Yes.
>> Mikel Markez: Il y avait
un groupe qui s'appelle
"Ez dok amairu."
Ils sont des chanteurs, qui ont
fait des nouvelles chansons,
qui ont fait des expérimentations,
mais qui ont pris des vielles
chansons traditionelles,
et des romans vieux, et qui les
ont chantées et ont popularisé
ces chansons.
Et tout le monde qui nous sommes
venus apres, tous les chanteurs,
tous les gens culturels, nous avons
apris que c'est très intéressant
ce que des autres ont fait avant,
pour faire nous qui a
de raiz, avec la terre.
C'est pour ça je pense que nous
avons eu un bon école avec ce
groupe qui est notre premier
réference culturel grand après,
un peu de le dictateur.
Et je pense que c'est pour ça que
la culture traditionelle a beaucoup
de force au Pays Basque.
Mais il y a une chose que je veux
dire de les chansons vielles et la
culture populaire ici
dans les États-Unis.
C'est vrai que nous
avons fait un travail,
et que des autres ont
fait un travail,
pour les chansons traditionelles.
Mais c'est vrai aussi que, comme la
culture au pays Basque est vivant,
il y a des nouveaux chansons,
il y a des nouveaux verses,
il y a des nouveaux...des
nouveaux influences du monde.
Et les choses vieux,
quelque fois, ils sont...
[mot Basque]
>> Andréa Bidart: Stabilized.
>> Begoña Echeverria: Fossilized.
>> Mikel Markez: [Basque word.]
>> Begoña Echeverria: Fossilized I
think is what he means; fossilized.
>> Stephen Winick:
Je comprends, oui.
>> Mikel Markez: Et ici,
nous pouvons écouter
quelques chansons que nous ne
connaissons pas.
>> Stephen Winick: Right.
>> Mikel Markez: Nous sommes, toute
la vie, apprendre des chansons.
Et nous pensons que nous savions
beaucoup de chansons populaires.
Mais c'est vrai que nous
venons a Chino, a Boise,
et il y a un vieux qui
chante une chanson que, oop!
Je connais pas!
Et c'est parce-que, pour nous,
c'est past autant important,
il y a des choses nouvelles.
Mais ici, c'est gardé!
>> Cathy Petrissans: That's
all we have, so [laughs] --
>> Mikel Markez: Dans les lieux
qui la culture Basque et pas fort,
nous pouvons rencontrer
quelques petits merveilles!
>> Stephen Winick: Oui,
c'est intéressant!
>> Mikel Markez: Oui, Oui, Oui,
>> Stephen Winick: Alors,
vous composez des chansons
aussi en Basque.
Est-ce-que vous utilisez
les vers traditionelles?
>> Mikel Markez: Oui...je
dirais que, moi,
j'ai trois chemins
qui sont ensembles.
D'une fois, je fais des chansons,
moi, des paroles et des musiques.
D'autre fois, je fais des musiques
pour des paroles qui ont fait
d'autres poètes ou
d'autres écrivains.
Et la troisieme, c'est
la chanson populaire.
Tous les disques, je pense,
j'ai chanté une ou deux chansons
populaires qui nous sont venues par
la tradition orale.
>> Stephen Winick: Okay.
Du temps qui n'avait pas la
possibilite d'enregistrer.
>> Stephen Winick: Okay.
>> Stephen Winick: Et de quels
sujets écrivez-vous dans
vos chansons?
>> Mikel Markez: Bon, J'écris de
tous les choses qui intéressent
à l'humain...
à l'humanité: La
mort, l'amour, le sexe,
la politique...tous les
choses...les rélations...la vie!
>> Stephen Winick: Oui.
>> Mikel Markez: Le vent...tout!
>> Stephen Winick: Et vous
etes guitariste, aussi.
>> Mikel Markez: Oui,
je joue la guitare,
je joue un peu l'accordéon
traditionnel Basque,
trikitixa, il s'appelle
>> Stephen Winick: Trikitixa.
C'est l'accordéon diatonique?
>> Mikel Markez: L'accordéon
diatonique, oui.
L'accordéon diatonique
traditionnel Basque.
>> Stephen Winick: Et la guitare,
est-ce-que c'est assez
nouvelle dans la musique Basque?
>> Mikel Markez: Nous avons des
évidences qu'il y avait...bon,
il y a beaucoup d'années, chanteurs
traditionnels avec la guitare...
>> Stephen Winick: Mm-hm.
>> Mikel Markez: ...et
aussi le violon...
>> Stephen Winick: Oui.
>> Mikel Markez: ...qui
chantaient des vers vieux,
des vers...qui content
des histoires comme,
qu'il y a une personne
qui a tué son pere,
et après il a été
condamné à mort.
Ils content des histoires,
et il y avait des groupes qui
vont de village en village,
en chantant l'histoire
des personnes,
ou les histoires de la guerre, ou
les histoires du roi qui est allé,
et qu'ils on dit a son
femme qu'il était mort,
mais il retourne, et il se déguise
>> Stephen Winick: Right [laughs].
>> Mikel Markez: Il y a beaucoup
d'histoires qui sont dans tous les
traditions de l'Europe,
ou du monde, non?
C'est les memes histoires,
en chaque lieu,
avec ces petits characterizations...
>> Stephen Winick: Des
petits différences.
>> Mikel Markez: Des
petits différences, oui.
>> Stephen Winick: Okay.
>> Stephen Winick: Il y
a des autres cultures,
disons minoritaires, en
France et en Espagne.
Je veux dire, par example,
les Occitanes, les Catalans.
Je sais que ce sont
des langues Romanes,
et que la langue Basque n'est
pas...Basque n'a aucun rélation à
ces langages, mais, est-ce-qu'il
y a de collaborations entre
ces cultures?
>> Mikel Markez: Oui, oui, oui.
Pour le pays Basque, où il etait
tout le temps la langue Basque,
et ils sont passés tous,
les Romans, les Arabes,
tout le monde est passé, et
tout le monde il l'a laissé.
Il y a beaucoup de mots,
il y a beaucoup, beaucoup,
beaucoup de mots...notre
langage, c'est pre-Indoeuropéene.
C'est avant tous les langues Latines
et tous les langues Germaniques.
Il n'y a...en Europe il n'y a pas
un langage qui est plus ancien que
le Basque.
Mais les Basques ont aussi beaucoup,
beaucoup, beaucoup de paroles,
et des expressions,
surtout des langages Latins.
>> Stephen Winick: Oui, bien sur.
>> Mikel Markez: C'est
[Basque word].
>> Stephen Winick: Okay.
>> Mikel Markez: Mélangé!
Mélangé!
>> Stephen Winick:
Mélangé, oui, Merci!
Parlez un peu de l'expérience
du Smithsonian Folklife Festival.
>> Mikel Markez: C'est tres
intéressant, parce-que,
comme Cathy a dit, nous avons le
possibilité de montrer ce que nous
faisons, évidemment, mais nous
avons le possibilité d'apprendre
des autres cultures, parce-que
nous sommes ici avec Sounds
of California, aussi, et
avec la culture américain.
Pour nous, c'est tres
riche, c'est impressionant.
>> Stephen Winick: Okay.
Merci [background laughter].
So if there's -- are there any
other things that we didn't address
that any of you want to say?
[ Basque Language Spoken ]
>> Begoña Echeverria:
So we have a --
[ Basque Language Spoken ]
The -- I know that -- so in addition
to the Alan Lomax collection,
there was a collection called
songs -- "Folk Songs of France".
>> Stephen Winick: Mm-hm.
>> That I remember hearing when I
was in the archives, and I was asked
to translate those songs
for the Smithsonian blog.
And it just so happens that there
is a song that is archived here,
that is sung by -- and is a group --
an all-male group in the French side
in the 40s, that we sang in
our first CD, the three of us.
And it was only after we
recorded it, that we realized
that there's a lot
of Noka in the song.
It's a song from --
[ Basque Language Spoken ]
I know he was like --
Yeah, so he was -- he was -- I'm not
sure of the exact date of this song,
but he was -- [Basque
language spoken
in background] -- 1890s, so --
[ Basque Language Spoken ]
So -- and yeah, and that's
where your family -- no?
[ Basque Language Spoken ]
So we think he's from
the town of what?
[ Basque Language Spoken ]
From the province of Lapurdi,
one of the French Basque -- yeah.
So he was very prolific.
And this song that he wrote,
it's -- uses a lot of Noka.
And it's called, "The
Party for Women",
and it seems like just a fun song.
These four women, they're
playing cards --
Cathy mentioned cards in the
shade, and they're gambling.
And then they drink a little
bit too much, so they're --
I don't play Mouche, but
apparently it's a card game
that -- where they pass signs.
>> Stephen Winick: Mm-hm.
>> Begoña Echeverria: And
that they're drinking so much
that they not -- they're passing --
they're not understanding
each other's signs.
So it seems like a fun
-- like they're just --
like they're having a really
good time, just like men do.
But at the very end
of the song it turns
out that they're witches [laughs].
>> Stephen Winick: Wow.
>> Begoña Echeverria:
So we would like to --
we're working on a reworking of the
song that is sort of a spin on that,
which is a swing version
of the song.
[ Basque Language Spoken ]
>> Andréa Bidart: Just the note.
>> Cathy Petrissans: Just the
note [Basque language spoken
in background].
>> Begoña Echeverria:
just the note.
>> Cathy Petrissans:
Just to find a note.
>> Begoña Echeverria:
>> Andréa Bidart: What
do you think it is?
>> Stephen Winick:
Just to get a note.
>> Begoña Echeverria:
I think it's [singing].
>> Cathy Petrissans: Yeah.
>> Andréa Bidart: Yeah.
>> Begoña Echeverria:
Is that right?
So if we screw up, because it's the
first time we've sung that public,
we want to start again, so --
[ Basque Language Spoken ]
>> Begoña Echeverria: Hold on.
I'll move it a little bit like that.
Is that okay Cathy?
>> Cathy Petrissans: Uh-huh.
>> Andréa Bidart: Okay.
>> Begoña Echeverria: So
we're going to sing -- how --
wait, how many verses
did we decide, all of it?
>> Cathy Petrissans: All of it.
>> Begoña Echeverria:
So we're going
to sing four verses,
sort of a swing version.
Let's see if you like it.
>> Stephen Winick: Okay.
>> Begoña Echeverria: Here we go.
[ Singing in Basque Language ]
>> Stephen Winick: Wow.
That was great.
Thank you so much.
>> Cathy Petrissans: So
the traditional is slower;
a little different [laughs].
>> Stephen Winick: Well, I
can't think of a better way
to end a oral history than that.
[ Basque Language Spoken ]
>> Cathy Petrissans: It's oral
and it's history [laughs].
>> Mikel Markez: Basque, English --
>> Begoña Echeverria: Swing --
>> Mikel Markez: American.
>> Andréa Bidart: Basque-American.
>> Begoña Echeverria:
Basque-American swing.
All mixed together.
>> Stephen Winick: Mélange.
>> Mikel Markez: Mélange.
>> Begoña Echeverria: Mélange.
[ Basque Language Spoken
and Laughter ]
>> Stephen Winick:
Well, thank you so much.
>> Andréa Bidart:
Thank you so much.
>> Begoña Echeverria: Thank
you for this opportunity.
>> Narrator: This has
been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.